what is this place I'm sorry to be the
one to tell you this but you got
yourself killed welcome to your weekend
ticket let's start off by taking a look
at the biggest box office stories from
this past weekend Pixar's newest film
onward dominated the weekend box office
as the debut 240 million its first
weekend the brother adventure story to
reconnect with a dead father who's come
back to life for one day and a bit of
sorcery as a pair of pants is the first
non sequel from the popular animation
studio since Coco and 2017
back then Coco debut 251 million over a
Thanksgiving weekend 2020 is looking a
lot like 2015 for Pixar as the year the
studio released two original films
inside out and the good dinosaur and
after onward Pixar also has the original
summer movies sold to be released June
19th The Invisible Man came in second
with another 15 million which pushes its
total gross so far above 50 million the
Blum House horror film has already
earned back more than seven times its
production budget in the US alone with
that level of return Universal has
already tapped James Wan director of the
saw and Aquaman franchises to produce
the next original low-budget monster
movie for the studio universals vintage
catalog is packed with iconic monsters
such as Dracula Frankenstein The Mummy
The Wolfman
The Creature from the Black Lagoon and
of course The Invisible Man and Ben
Affleck returned to theaters for the
first time since 2017 with the way back
helm by gavin o'connor the adult drama
about a recovering alcoholic basketball
coach debuted to 9 million over the
weekend Affleck was last seen on the big
screen in Justice League but the last
non Batman performance from the actor
that played in theaters was his own
directed live by night which debuted at
the end of 2016
we start this week's releases with a
comic book superhero new to the big
screen and bloodshot
Vin Diesel plays Marine ray garrison who
was murdered along with his wife but has
given a new chance at life this time
pumped full of strength enhancing and
health regenerating nanomachines but
unbeknownst to Ray his memories of the
past life have been erased and implanted
with new ones by the people that
resurrected him when his memories
suddenly flood back he decides to break
free of being controlled and seek
revenge on his killer
bloodshot is neither ADC nor a Marvel
character but a character from Valiant
Comics making this their first
live-action superhero film so maybe this
could be the start of the Valiant Comics
universe and as we like to give you a
little extra info here on weekend ticket
here's a look at bloodshot in comic book
form need now let's take a look at some
new movies you can watch at home
starting with uncut gems in another
serious role for Adam Sandler a
jeweler's gambling habits have put his
life in all sorts of danger and pushed
him to frantically scramble to keep one
step ahead of those out to collect his
balancing act becomes a non-stop ride
from beginning to end and uncut gems is
certified fresh with a 92% on the tomato
meter also Adam Sandler said if he
wasn't nominated for an Oscar for this
role he would get his revenge by making
the worst movie ever and I for one can't
wait to see that movie also available to
watch at home this weekend is bombshell
bombshell revisits the rise of a handful
of female reporters at Fox News who set
out to expose CEO Roger Ailes for sexual
harassment the film stars Nicole Kidman
Margot Robbie John Lithgow and Charlize
Theron who once again perfectly
transformed into her role this time as
reporter megan kelly bombshell was
nominated for three Academy Awards one
for Margot Robbie one for Charlize
Theron and it won the Oscar for best
hair and makeup that's this week's
weekend ticket leave us a comment and
let us know what you will be watching
this weekend I'm Cal nonnamous and I'll
see you next week
[Music]